how are we supposed to beat this thing  we need a plan knuckles use your  strength to  jump off the plane wow okay this is what  we're gonna do step one light taunting  step two i have no idea  sonic  nice action figure eggman does it do  anything or just stand there looking  ugly  [Music]  like a blister he keeps coming back  he's on the okay to kill list shoot the  missiles make a decision uh i i just  need a moment sir i'm trying to figure  out how to do this did you even glance  at emmanuel  i'll do it  pardon my lightning  you might want to ground yourself  oh  i'm gonna pop that thing open like a can  of chili  [Music]  die mosquito  oh  i felt that  [Music]  what just happened  it's the stashmasher right here in the  manual  return  oh great  next thing you know there'll be a report  about a hostile work environment